[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro et oui le compte à
rebours est terminée vous êtes donc avec
nous on est en direct c'est figaro
l'arrivée et on attend vos points de vue
vos opinions les confrontera ce soir
avec les analyses de jérôme jaffré
politologue et patron du cecop banc ce
soir jérôme merci d'être avec nous merci
de ce grand retour sur le plateau de
figaro là et qu'une joie et c'est une
joie partagée partager également avec
guillaume tabard analystes et
chroniqueur politique
auteurs tous les jours du contrepoint
dans l'édition papier du figaro on
signale aussi l'indispensable ouvrage
collectif que vous avez dirigé avec jean
christophe buisson les grandes figures
de la droite perd 1 c'est chez perrin et
ce soir on va se pencher je sais pas si
c'est une grande figure en tous les cas
c'est l'une de ses plus grandes gueules
marine le pen quelles sont ses chances
réelles
gauche et droite joue-t-elle à se faire
peur en brandissant sa menace
les sondages sont ils trompeur vous avez
ce soir le meilleur la crème de la crème
de l'analyse politique
en plateau alors j'attends vos questions
mais d'abord et j'ai oublié de vous le
préciser en titre on va désolé mais
encore revenir sur le coronavirus sur le
co vide et sous l'angle politique avec
cette question de savoir si le pari des
manuels mâcon et trop risqué à ce que
l'opinion peut le suivre ça fait donc
une semaine que le président de la
république a créé la surprise en
refusant de décider 1re confinement et
cette décision ne manque pas de faire
débat
à l'opposé opposé à cette décision on le
sent bien le corps scientifique dans
tous les cas le corps médical notamment
illustré par cette réponse ce matin de
rémy salomon à ne pas confondre avec
jérôme rémy lui il est l'un des
responsables de l'assistance publique
des hôpitaux de paris
parce que justement le variant arrivant
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure le
variant on sait qu'il va prendre le
dessus
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans d'autres
pays quoique ont quoi qu'on fasse il est
plus transmissible est plus contagieux
donc il va de toute façon prendre le
dessus et est en plus contagieux ce que
l'on les mesures qu'on a prises
aujourd'hui sont ne seront probablement
pas suffisantes
c'est énorme soit 50 à 70% de
contagiosité en plus c'est énorme c'est
à dire que voilà les toutes les mesures
qu'on a prises jusque là sont moins
efficaces les mesures sont moins
efficaces alors côté plutôt favorables
au président de la république
et bien il y a les politiques en
particulier l'ancien premier ministre
jean pierre raffarin
je pense qu'il a bien fait d'abord et il
a montré une sensibilité humaine où
toutes les difficultés qu'ont les
français actuellement
et ça je pense que c'est important de
penser aux étudiants de penser à tous
ceux qui souffrent psychologiquement qui
souffrent dans leur être de cette
situation sans parler naturellement de
ceux qui sont en situation économique
sinistré jérôme guillaume comment vous
analysé cette dichotomie cet écart de
points de vue c'est le retour du
politique
j'en ai goûté c'est en tout cas le
retour du président dans la vie
politique et dans la vème république
avec sa toute puissance
la capacité décidées la capacité de
surprendre
et donc c'est un trait caractéristique
quand on regarde et je parle sous le
contrôle de guillaume tabard dans la
mémoire et ils sont des faux mitterrand
par exemple quand il interrogé à la
télévision en plein période de l'ex
yougoslavie et qui dit alors que
sarajevo est en guerre j'irai à sarajevo
lui dit quand il répond demain c'est
évidemment aussi nicolas sarkozy le
discours de toulon où il dit que tous
les avoirs des français dans la crise
financière seront protégés points une
décision majeure c'est françois hollande
qui annonce que dans la journée les
troupes françaises seront mali ce soir
voilà c'est on n'intervient donc
donc c'est vraiment un des grands
classiques de la fonction présidentielle
extrêmement fort alors encore faut-il
que le coût soit bien calculer ce que
vient de dire rémy salomon d'une
certaine façon c'est à dire qu'il ne
faut pas que le président soit pris à
contre-pied en moins d'une semaine dix
jours est obligé de procéder d'ici une
semaine dix jours à ce confinement qu'il
a décidé de ne pas suivre
à ce moment là je dirais que cela se
retournerait certainement contre lui
comme une décision somme toute il
réfléchit solitaire et dangereuse donc
il y aurait tous les inconvénients voilà
c'est dans ce sens 36 chose si je vous
suis pardon je vous coupe il faut
maintenant reste sur le cap de cette de
cette décision il est évident que sur la
situation
quelle que soit la situation
entendons-nous est évident que si on les
hôpitaux se mettre à crier les malades
ne serait pas pardonné au président de
ne pas changer de cap mais encore
faut-il qu'ils aient un minimum de
cohérence
l'idée c'est qu'un plateau élevé mais
que ce plateau élevé n'est pas à monter
exponentielle et donc que la décision du
président peut s'expliquer ce justifié
c'est ça le calcul présidentielle et
qui a surpris tout le monde et d'abord
les français diouf oui je suis je suis
totalement ce que dira jérôme à propos
du retour du président de la république
dans sa fonction celui qui prend la
décision qui en l'occurrence qu'on se le
dire a eu le courage de prendre les
décisions et une décision presque
contre-intuitif en tout cas qui va aller
à l'encontre des pronostics dominant je
crois que c'est aussi le retour du
maquereau nisme à savoir de cette
capacité transgressive qui a fait le
succès initial dm d'emmanuel macron
alors on peut lire en terme
psychologique pour dire il n'aime pas
qu'on lui dicte ce qu'il doit faire il
prend presque un malin plaisir à faire
l' inverse de ce qu on dise que tout le
monde lui conseille même s'ils voient
cette capacité de 200 du club l'un des
mots c'est un des moteurs qu'on lui
prête dans cette décision
finalement ce sera quand même un grand
coup dgo non mais encore il ya une
intuition dans une turquie aussi fondée
sur le fait qu'il est président la
république chef de l'état chef parle
parfois quand il parlait français il dit
mon peuple président des français et
avoir soin des français protégé les
français
c'est bien sûr protéger leur santé mais
c'est protéger leur licence dans tous
ses aspects y compris économiques y
compris psychologique et je trouve ça
assez
presque cocasse de d'opposer au
président rémy salomon a conquis
viennent une fois de plus donner des
chiffres alarmistes et nous dire que
c'était dramatique si ma mémoire est
bonne c'est le même rémy salle aux maux
qui avant noël nous enjoignent et de
faire dîner papis et mamies à la cuisine
le peuple veut ton si l'on me rappelle
nicole et je crois que là et ça s'est
indigné de l'avoir entendue et mais s'il
en est d'une certaine manière moi aussi
ce que désire ce n'est pas le sujet
direct de notre discussion de ce soir
sur la prise de risque politique d'
emmanuel macron mais en tout cas je
pense que l'intervention de rémy salomon
montrent bien comment une logique
strictement comptable sanitaires on
surveille une courbe de deux cas une
courbe d'entrée à l'hospital notre même
6 il important de la suivre et d'y être
vigilant peut aller jusqu'à oublier et
nié tout principe d'humanité
papy et mamie à la cuisine bon ben là
pareil si on suit cette logique purement
comptable il fallait être confiné de
toute urgence de manière préventive et
avec certaines garanties c'est qu'on
sait que mécaniquement le confinement
produit des effets donc on sait que si
on avait confiné
oui on allait faire baisser
immédiatement le nombre de cas mais
emmanuel macron cas peser l'ensemble des
facteurs a pris en compte aussi le
risque sur l'état l'état psychologique
ont des français et je pense qu'ils
aient pensé qu'il y avait plus de danger
à confiner dès maintenant qu'à attendre
un peu personnellement moi je vous donne
raison
pardon je vous donne la parole tout de
suite jérôme et je rebondis sur ce que
disait guillaume dit c'est le retour du
maquereau nisme qui identifie avec de la
transgression le maquereau nice mais
c'est aussi dû en même temps si macron
fait du macron si macron fait du en même
temps là il prend énormément de risques
puisqu'il prend le risque de ne pas être
cohérent ce qui est à vous entendre le
risque majeur et deuxièmement c'est
effectivement et ce que vient de dire
guillaume l'illustrent c'est une rupture
dans la période de la crise de la
pandémie
c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est à dire que la crise de la pandémie
ne peut plus être regardée de la même
façon comme un bloc à partir du moment
où le président considère que l'objectif
sanitaire certes est essentielle mais
qui n'est pas le seul et qu'il prend de
plus en plus en compte les autres
problèmes
qui est d'abord le problème étant la
difficulté des français à vivre un
nouveau confinement tout simplement la
souffrance que ça représenterait pour
les français la difficulté du peuple à
subir cette dimension supplémentaire
avec les conséquences profondes
sanitaires aussi d'ailleurs mais
économiques sociales psychologiques qui
s'ensuivrait à partir de ce moment là
les débats se modifie et ski quand même
est intéressant dans ce maquereau nisme
le maquereau nisme j'avais dit une fois
dans une interview du figaro de
pardonnez moi de me citer c'est le
défaut terrible on vous en voudra pas
c'était le fil des ronces et celle des
faux terrible des universitaires ils
ceux ci de même puisque personne ne les
cite soyons lucides le maquereau nisme
se définit comme une pyramide qui repose
sur la pointe à partir de ce moment là
il est frappant de constater à quel
point le maquereau a surpris tout le
monde mais il a désavoué ses ministres
son premier ministre qui dans les jours
qui précédaient les heures qui
précédaient tenait un discours une
position exactement inverse
ce qui signifie une forme
d'affaiblissement de la parole politique
or celle d' emmanuel macron ceux qui ne
le déplaît pas forcément et deuxièmement
il a également désavoué très fortement
le conseil scientifique et tous les
sachants c'est à dire que là aussi le
professeur delfraissy quelques jours
avant avait fait une déclaration sur une
chaîne d'information continue où il
disait en gros
il ya le feu au lac et il ya urgence
absolue puis deux jours plus tard et 10
et on n'est pas une semaine presque y
est elle une cohérence limité il faut en
convenir
mais du coup le conseil scientifique est
remis à sa place et je lisais sans doute
dans le figaro que emmanuel macron il
avait été très frappé dans son
intervention de fin octobre quand il
disait on va confiné à nouveau il avait
dit quoi que nous fassions il y aura
neuf mille personnes en réanimation à la
mi novembre
quoique nous fassions or ya jamais eu
neuf mille personnes en réanimation à la
mi novembre et se sont tassées régime
aux élections une modélisation
mathématique mais doit s'attacher les
services fournis par les scientifiques
mais c'est le discours de tous ces
sachants et de tous ces scientifiques ce
qui fait qu emmanuel macron
manifestement a pris la décision de
s'éloigner donc c'est une rupture pour
moi dans la crise sans des mythes alors
cet internaute nous dit bravo enfin une
prise de risque
à propos d' emmanuel macron moi je vous
a posé la question sur twitter bien sûr
une question sur twitter c'est c'est
absolument pas une consultation c'est
absolument pas un sondage absolument pas
une étude
je parle sous le contrôle draconien de
jérôme jaffré et guillaume tabard et
donc on vous pose la question approuvez
vous la décision d' emmanuel macron de
ne par confiner et vous répondez vous
pour l'instant majoritairement oui à 60
% or selon un sondage ifop pour le
journal du dimanche
60% des français exactement l'inversé
sont favorables à un recond finement et
quand on regarde les sous catégories et
bien ce qui est intéressant c'est que la
plus importante est celle des plutôt
favorable voyez c'est celle qui est en
bas en bleu ciel 36%
viennent ensuite les très favorable qui
sont un petit peu plus au dessus en
orange 23% et ne viennent ensuite
qu'ensuite les plutôt défavorable en
bleu ciel bleu foncé 24% et en tout
dernier n'est pas du tout favorable à
l'or macron dans ces conditions de la
pâte il n'a t-il pas pris un ris pari
risqué très risqué mais d'abord je pense
qu'il fallait au bout de ce même sondage
le sondage donnait feignant une
approbation majoritaire d'un nouveau
confinement dans son concept global met
ensuite six
encore ma mémoire est bonne le sondage a
interrogé les gens sur des modalités
concrètes de ce confinement fermeture
des écoles fermeture des restaurants
fermeture des librairies les transports
de sahara bank et quand on prenait thème
par thème
l'opinion était à tout le moins
nettement plus partagés et dans certains
cas franchement hostile ce que dira qu'
il ya une adhésion globale au concept de
confinement mais dans les aspects
concrets ben non ça s'annonce annonça
non donc on arrive à l'arrivée anna
finalement une sorte de confinement like
qui a été plutôt celui de nos du mois du
mois de novembre ottoman donc ça allait
ensuite da sur le risque qui il est réel
parce que je pense qu'il ya dans
l'opinion dont la population est en
chacun de nous ce mélange entre un désir
de liberté et donc une lassitude à
l'égard des contraintes en tous genres
lassitude parce que c'est pas agréable
ou lassitude parce que ça met clairement
en péril une activité professionnelle et
donc son existence même est il ya
symétriquement et simultanément à une
peur une peur de ce virus on est on est
vraiment ryan une crainte objectif plus
une peur qui a entretenu depuis un an à
l'égard de la dangerosité de ce de ce
virus qui fait que oui on veut quand
même être protégé on veut pas qu'il
circule donc il ya cette ambivalence
vous parle hitler du en même temps ma
chronique le même temps il est dans
l'esprit de chacun d'où ces réponses qui
peuvent partager ton qui maniait de la
crau il fait un choix
je pense qu'en sachant que quel que soit
le choix qu'il est fait il y aura par
définition la moitié de gens pour le
pour le critiquer il aurait confiné
une partie des gens une grande partie
des genres dits mais enfin ça y est on
nous a supprimé toute liberté on ne peut
plus vivre c'est intolérable et je pense
de manière sincère il ne confine pas
d'autres personnes et parfois les mêmes
disent attention ils jouent avec le feu
joli coup revendiquée par monsieur louis
dans le missouri mai mais il peut se
développer
j'espère développer peut-être certains
internautes qui nous disent il n'y a pas
de troisième vague macro aura eu raison
au pire il aura tenté de maintenir une
situation acceptable
est ce que ça peut être ça le pari des
manuels macron et finalement ça peut
être une ligne qui peut être tenu
même si il y à une remontée très forte
des chiffres de contamination
d'hospitalisation c'est vrai que c'est
au bilan qu'on jugera et le bilan ce
sera aussi la comparaison du nombre de
morts par rapport au nombre d'habitants
dans les différents pays européens ça ce
sera un critère décisif
deuxièmement c'est l'image des hôpitaux
dans les prochaines semaines esquissant
total surcharge avec des chefs de
service qu'on voit sur les écrans de
télévision dire on n'y arrive pas nous
craignons de voir faire le tri entre les
malades c'est ça les vrais risques
mais si effectivement on est dans une
situation où on arrive quand même à
contrôler l'épidémie et à tenir les
services de santé tout en évitant ce
confinement général du pays emmanuel mac
on pourra en tirer les bénéfices
la réponse favorable des français l'idée
du confinement
elle renvoie en partie aussi à l'idée de
l'auto confinement je dirais c'est à
dire que pour beaucoup de gens je limite
- très sérieusement les relations et les
interactions sociales comme on dit
maintenant dans les ministères ce que
personne ne comprend ce à dire les
rencontres entre les gens parlons
simplement je limite pas rigoureusement
je limite rigoureusement les rencontres
que j'ai et d'une certaine façon donc je
m'auto confine et beaucoup de personnes
âgées d'ailleurs le fond d'elle-même
cette situation mais ils en ont tout le
monde en a assez évidemment c'est une
situation terrible
enfin dernier élément c'est que ces
discussions sur le confinement
macron ne pense sortir vainqueur que par
une réussite sur le vaccin
et c'est l'idée du vaccin qui était
terriblement absente de la communication
vendredi dernier à fin du premier
ministre et du gouvernement
si nous sommes entrés dans une période
où le vaccin peut s'accélérer dans les
deux prochains mois très sérieusement
vous entretenir l'espoir dans le pays et
vous recréer une dynamique positive
si on continue de dire en revanche les
doses n'arrive pas on devrait faire mal
et apparemment c'est ce qui est quand
même c'est ce qui se profile comme
tendance peut-être peut-être que les
choses iront en s'améliorant olivier
véran dans le débat à l'assemblée
nationale des questions d'actualité cet
après-midi maintenait à son risque
personnel très grand compte tenu des
chiffres qui l'a annoncé lui même que
dans les prochains mois nous aurions
nous continuerions sur une dynamique
positive
il faut que le vaccin deviennent la
dynamique positive de lutte contre
l'épidémie
c'est l'enjeu politique au delà du pari
fait par emmanuel macron dont vous
parlez c'est l'enjeu oui alors c'est
l'enjeu dans ces conditions lio mais est
ce que vraiment c'est pas risquer très
risqué de la part de mâcon au regard de
ce que l'on peut observer en ce moment
sur les sur le vaccin et surtout sans
vouloir lui faire injure quand olivier
véran le même qui avait dit que le
confinement était pas nécessaire avant
que ne soit décidée un confinement qui
avait quand même tenu le discours qu'on
a connus sur les masques sur les tests
etc
ce masque sur le confinement ont trait à
olivia vend à tour est poussé au conflit
au maximum oui enfin on a encore des
propos d'emmanuel d'olivier véran sur le
plateau de bfm
quelques jours avant le confinement en
disant que finalement c'était pas si ce
n'était pas la meilleure chose à faire
puisque les gens pouvaient être
contaminées par le confinement donc
c'est il a peut être parlé à son corps
défendant ce jour-là m'enfin il a
déclaré donc c'est pour ça je vous dis
est-ce que et olivier veron est très
crédible quand il dit aujourd'hui que
finalement la stratégie vaccinale pourra
finalement se poursuivre bassin qui
s'engager sur des chiffres ce qu'il a
rappelé aujourd'hui ce qu'il avait
annoncé dans un 20 heures à télévision
avec ces fameux chiffres
exponentielle finissant à 70 millions de
français vaccinés d'ici au mois d'août
ce qui veut dire que par parenthèse du 6
mois d'août nous aurons gagné quasiment
3 3 millions et demi d'habitants en plus
ce qui est une bonne nouvelle
nourrissons compris vacciner mais au
delà de la boutade effet il a voulu
donner ce sentiment de michel debré
voilà parce que souvenez vous la
polémique au début tout premiers
chiffres 1 maurice chez nous et
mauricette est vacciné ailleurs on en
est déjà quelques dizaines ou centaines
de milliers le guen m'a dit mais ne le
début ne prenez pas ça en compte
j'allais voir dès qu'on va être lancée
on va rattraper tout le monde et on
s'engage on va arriver à un million
avant la fin du mois de janvier
effectivement avant la fin du mois de
janvier on était un million mais dans
disco initial du gouvernement c'était on
prend notre envol et après ça continue
de plus belle or depuis qu'on a atteint
ce seuil d'un million là c'est plutôt
l'air sonné ça progresse beaucoup trop
lentement pour toutes les raisons qu'on
a 10 de retard de livraison de deux de
retard d'agrément de certains de vaccins
sert donc c'est pas il n'y a pas de
responsabilité directe du gouvernement
dans ces manque d'approvisionnement mais
en tout cas il y avait un message de
dire ça une fois qu'on est lancé
ça accélère et on a lyon il ne ralentit
plus
si on voit qu'en ce moment ça cafouille
un peu ça vient compte rapport de l'ifa
atteint l'arrivée ça c'est non seulement
inquiétant mais c'est anxiogène parce
que le message symbolique versailles et
maintenant on est on a engagé ce combat
là il prend 1 il prend un coup dans l
approuvez vous la décision d' emmanuel
macron de ne par confiner c'est la
question qu'on me pose sur twitter
emmanuel macron n'a pas exclu
l'hypothèse d'un confinement il a rejeté
le caractère préventif nous dit babineau
pas de débat sur figaro live cette
citation de bobino on est dans le en
même temps juste un mot pour conclure
jambes sur cette partie leur guillaume a
tout dit je vous propose d'attaquer
marine le pen avait c'est votre point de
vue effectivement nous on a une question
c'est sur les chances réelles de man in
here in le pen en 2022 vous savez la
semaine dernière on vous parlait donc
d'un sondage harris interactive
et comme nous sommes occupés ni qu'il
était pour nos confrères de l'opinion
mais l'intérêt c'était qu'il montrait
que la responsable résidente du
rassemblement national rester en tête et
était resté qualifié pour le 2e tour
pour la présidentielle de 2000 à 2022 et
qu'elles étaient en tête ce qu'on a pas
dit à ce moment-là parce que justement
ces chiffres n'avaient pas été publiée
officiellement
c'est que au second tour la présidente
du rassemblement national serait crédité
de 48 % des voix quand tu % jérôme on
entre dans la marge d'erreur est ce que
c'est sérieux ça pas été publié mais
est-ce que c'est sérieux de voir marine
le pen à 40% au deuxième tour écoutez
c'est stupéfiant en tout cas c'est une
stupéfaction d'abord je prends ce
sondage avec des pincettes pour deux
raisons d'une part c'est un sondage
confidentiel on ne sait pas pour qui
comment on en a pas les données on ne
peut pas analyser les transferts les
ventilations fait tout ce qui nous
ferait normal voudra les deux chiffres
du 2ème tour du chiffre du deuxième
c'est le 52 48 lits et bouleverse
vous comprenez jean marie le pen il a
fait 18% face à jacques chirac en 2002
marine le pen elle fait 34% face à
emmanuel macron en 2017 si nous étions à
48%
c'est un jeu c'est un bouleversement du
jeu politique donc je le prend avec des
pincettes car c'est un sondage
confidentiel dont on ignore tout à part
le fait qu'il n'a pas été démenti il
faudrait qu'il soit confirmé par
d'autres sondages et puis là je parle
d'expérience un sondage fait le
longtemps à l'avancé avant la
présidentielle et bien évidemment il ne
nous annonce rien sur ce que sera la
présidentielle mais il nous dit beaucoup
sur le jeu politique
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre ce une
enquête si supposons qu'elle se trouve
confirmée par d'autres enquêtes car cela
le plaisir un peu de notre discussion
c'est un bouleversement complet du jeu
politique marine le pen entre
effectivement dans la zone de la
victoire possible mais je dirais que
marine le pen ne peut ne pourrait gagner
que face emmanuel que face à emmanuel
macron comme emmanuel macron semble-t-il
n'a vraiment de chance sérieuse et
solide de gagner que s'il se retrouve
face à marine le pen
en d'autres termes c'est un duo qui
fonctionne totalement ensemble
aujourd'hui alors le sondage du premier
tour de l'opinion que vous avez indiqué
qu'il lui ait publié que nous avons pu
étudier et regarder de plus près dit
bien que les deux sont largement en tête
mais ce qui frappe et guillaume tabard
le disais dans une interview dans son
contrepoint récent du figaro il ya une
fragilité aujourd'hui des positions
politiques y a il ya des jeux de
circulation des électorats qui ne sont
pas du tout figé et donc là aussi je le
prends avec précaution mais s'il
sondages à 52,48 se trouve confirmée je
vous annonce que le jeu politique
français est transformée dans les
prochains mois alors on va revenir sur
justement tout ce que vous dites
pour vous donner avant de vous donner la
parole pour chaque vidéo
je voudrais qu'on la donne à lui dire
oui également la donne ne pas obliger je
voudrais pour l'album à damien abad qui
était qui a commenté également ces
chiffres hier sur le plateau d'auditions
publiques l'émission coproduite par
figaro live avec la chaîne parlementaire
public sénat
ça montre que emmanuel macron n'est plus
le rempart face au front national au
centre ont tous malgré tout sur le
terrain une montée de rassemblement
national
et donc ce que je dis simplement
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est très
dangereux de vouloir faire un match be
r entre le prix dans la lbeq sortant et
le rassemblement leur sueur et leur
ascension
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
damien abad ça prouve que mails macron
n'est plus le rempart face à marine le
pen et par rapport à ce que disait
jérôme est ce que alors c'est pour ça
qu'on a donné ces chiffres c'est qu'il
n'a pas été démenti mais est ce que
finalement ce ça reste un peu quand même
hypothétique
écoutez d'abord je pense pas ratifié
tous cas 10 0 me en terme d'analysé
surtout sera ainsi de nom mais je
partage entièrement son ton analyse
japon serait donc deux compléments et
kiki répondre à votre question une
première sur sur la nature quand même de
l'électorat jérôme a rappelé qu on
passait d'un jean marie le pen à 18% il
marine le pen à 34% et d'un potentiel
aujourd'hui que sont le reflet de 50%
mais ce socle jeu je corps électoral ça
n'est pas de même s'il y avait 48 % de
français qui votait marine le pen au
second tour d'après ancien de 2022
ça ne devrait pas dire que le stock
d'une droite radicale extrême qui avait
été retrouvé 18 % auraient grossi sais
aussi que je ne crois pas une à une
extrémité ation de l'électorat français
je crois en revanche à un élargissement
de la position de marine le pen et pour
le dire très clairement je pense qu'une
marine le pen 2022
en termes de 2,2 du jeu démocratique
cerrone ne représente pas du tout la
même réalité le même danger même menace
quel que soit le mot que l'on prenne
qu'un jean marie le pen de 2002 et 2002
dont sharp il faut prendre après c'est
le jeu du beau pays que de combattre des
adversaires assez comment certains de
ses détracteurs au sein du rassemblement
national pour vous suivre la
gauchisation de marine le pen pourrait
lui permettre de de ses passagers entre
je parlerai plus d'une forme de
normalisation électorale jantes pas dans
le débat de dédiabolisation au tac et
elle a sa stratégie à elle bon c c'est
une chose mais je pense qu à une
normalisation électorale ou sont sous le
lectorat des mains de marie le pen n'est
plus uniquement le baromètre d'un d'un
refus du système ça il est ultra se dit
elle est pas si dangereuse c'est ça
c'est ça que c'est l'évolution sans avec
tori de la perception séparé de le dire
il n'est pas si drôle c'est qu'il dit
n'est pas dangereuse vers calais et une
fois encore c'est quand tu % potentiel
ils votent sciemment feinte de corps sur
un volume de suffrages exprimés
ce serait un vote conscient et délibéré
en sa faveur
ensuite pour reprendre ce que disait
damien abad une évolution de la
perception de marine le pen par les
lecteurs c'est ça le truc deux versions
et de sa réalité
allez on va bien comprise dans les
thématiques sur lesquelles elle est
aujourd'hui
il ya eu un glissement par rapport à son
discours à son propre discours elle par
rapport à il ya dix ans au moment où
elle a pris le front national ensuite
quand damien abadie on nous impose ce
match macron le pen et donc c'est
dangereux
lr 10 à le ps le dilemme même manière en
gros tous ceux qui cherchent à trouver
une base refusons ce match qu'on nous
impose mais qui impose quoi les sondages
attendant d'avoir qui se construit dans
les votes mais les votes on l'a vu
notamment aux élections européennes un
électeur français il est libre non on ne
lui impose pas de voter ou mâcon où le
pen il sauf que pour l'instant pour
l'instant lorsqu'on demande aux acteurs
français de faire un choix
les deux forces qui apparaissent
dominante en tout cas largement en tête
c'est maquereau ou la sensibilité macro
nist et marine le pen où la sensibilité
du rassemblement national à la place de
damien abad d'anne hidalgo de yannick
jadot ou d'autres plutôt que de bourges
à dire de pleurnicher sur un machin
posée j'irai à eux de mettre dans le
débat une offre politique qui soit
suffisamment attrayante pour que les
électeurs se disent tiens cette offre là
elle m'intéresse plus
plus que sept autres je passe et ça ça
permet quand même je dirais de ré ouvrir
un peu les choses pour les oppositions
et c'est l'espoir évidemment d'amis un
bac pour la droite
sexy macron est en position si difficile
si c'est confirmé en position si
difficile face à marine le pen
la logique des électeurs et de chercher
un autre candidat pour porter le combat
contre marine le pen dont la position
effectivement est très solide
en d'autres termes votre problématique
et tourner vers marine le pen
mais les sondages que nous citons la
sont particulièrement intéressants sur
emmanuel macron lui même tout le monde a
ses chances
je dirais même que au second tour macre
on est sûr de gagner probablement encore
sur ces monnaies plus justice est
confirmée mais n'a vraiment des chances
très forte de victoires que face à
marine le pen
imaginez un xavier bertrand humain dit
dale go qui arriverait un second tour
face à emmanuel macron ce serait
extraordinairement difficile pour le
président sortant pourquoi parce que ce
que nous dit ce sondage que j'aimerais
pouvoir analyser je le répète mais bon
je suppute j'aime suppute jean daniel
lévy de nous envoyer les détails je
suppute c'est aussi ce sondage
extraordinaire donne ce 52/48 de second
tour il dit deux choses la première
c'est que les électeurs de gauche ne
veulent pas voter macron second tour et
la deuxième c'est qu'une partie
significative des électeurs de droite
votent marine le pen au second tour
en d'autres termes c'est c'est la
tectonique de la politique française se
trouve modifié et pour emmanuel macron
il se trouve à ce moment-là prisonnier
de son ego chenilles droite car il fait
éventuellement un 24 25 % de premier
tour mais ne trouve plus les ressources
suffisantes pour aller bien au-delà de
50% au second tour il est dans la zone
d'extrême fragilité
pour marine le pen je pense
qu'effectivement elle arrive à un moment
un seuil qui est intéressant françois
mitterrand en 1981 quand il était au
plus bas des sondages et compenser un
moment qui est manuel que même sur l
retards allaient l'emporter contre lui
il avait publié un livre d'entretiens et
il disait une phrase qui commençait
qu'il était dans le paysage politique
je fais partie du paysage politique et
marine le pen fait maintenant partie du
paysage politique
en d'autres termes ça n'est plus aussi
sulfureux que ça pullule s il fait
partie des mid un dernier mot les thèmes
aujourd'hui qui sont dans le débat de
souveraineté de frontières de risque de
déclassement de la france etc
marine le pen peut les utiliser pour
être portés et là il ya quelque chose
qui donne une substance au delà des
évolutions d'image alors 2-2 objection à
ce que vous n'êtes bien
la première c'est si on suit la logique
de ce que veut dire c'est que ça ça
marche quand on est sûr sur une sur une
posture radicale mais appartement aussi
on est sur une posture de normalisation
le fait de toutes les thématiques
d'immigration d'insécurité finalement
peut-être que
marine le pen peut être nous a
paradoxalement moins crédible sur ça et
puis deuxième objection dans le sens
scène de bobino la normalisation du rn
ne suffit pas il faut rassembler mais
change il ya elle a vraiment marine le
pen est face à deux difficultés
contradictoires la première qui est
plutôt celle d'où elle part c'est sa
difficulté et même pour l'instant son
incapacité totale à jeudi par élargir
son lectorat ce que ça lui arrive mais a
structuré une alliance politique qui la
déborde bon et s'attend qu'elle n'y
arrivera pas à le faire et là pour
l'instant il n'y a aucun élément qui
permet de penser qu'il puisse y arriver
elle rassure je prenne de crédibilité
politique non pas des gens diront elles
seraient pas faire ou cse mesures sont
mauvaises mais voilà un capacité à
structurer une offre politique elle est
au delà d'une alliance autour d'elle
voilà avec de nicolas dupont aignan mais
pas qu il savait mais bon capitaine a
créé être être un pôle de rassemblement
comme ça elle n'y arrive pas donc d'une
servir ces voulais y arriver il faudrait
qu'elle aille encore plus loin dans la
normalisation ça mais inversement
vous l'avez dit ce qui fait aussi sa
force et cette capacité de transgression
de rejet du système d'incarner cette
thématique transgressive et on a on a
beaucoup parlé d'eux
de trump bon trump a gagné sur une
intégralement transgressive et
contrairement au schéma qu'on peut avoir
habituellement dire bravo pour gagner on
force le trait mais une fois qu'on est
au pouvoir on s'assagit trucks ne sait
absolument pas assagi est resté
transgressif et agressive dans tous les
sens du terme on va jusqu'au bout non et
ça n'est pas passé loin mais il a gardé
quand même son socle électoral
voilà est aujourd'hui s'ils ne
l'espérons pas mais si la crise
sanitaire devait basculer dans quelque
chose de
de plus grâce si ses conséquences
sociales devaient être au delà de toutes
nos craintes
on ne sait pas quel serait l'état
d'exaspération du pays et peut-être que
face à un durcissement est un women pays
chahutés au delà de ce qu'on peut
imaginer un discours transgressif
pourrait trouver du répondant du
répondant mais que marine le pen ne
correspond plus aujourd'hui à ce
discours fortement transgressif dernière
dernière question et si macro ne se
représentait pas auraient-elles les
mêmes chances de sa reprend justement là
la théorie du duo eh bien je pense que
la chance de marine le pen c'est
emmanuel macron ai la chance d emmanuel
macron c'est marine le pen en et en
d'autres termes le duo fonctionne de
voilà ils ont besoin l'un de l'autre et
le problème aussi c'est que l'immense
majorité des français ne veut pas revoir
ce second tour et donc c'est très
important comme donner parce qu'ils
peuvent être à ce moment là la recherche
de la façon d'éjecter l'un ou l'autre du
second tour voire les deux et de ce
point de vue si ce sondage
extraordinaire de 48% il paraît que
marine le pen n'arrivais pas à y croire
et qu'il a fallu qu'elle attende le
lendemain et la confirmation qu'ils
soient venus pour dire ah ben c'est pas
possible j'en suis déjà là elle n'y
croyait pas elle-même mais du coup ça
change la donne politique profondément
si ça se confiant parce qu'à ce moment
là marine le pen n'est pas consignes et
n'est plus considérée comme la candidate
qui porte les mécontentements du pays d1
satisfait les renversant elle est
regardée à ce moment là comme possible
président
et du coup ça pose effectivement le
problème de savoir avec qui gouverner
sur quelle force exactement s'appuyer
pour appliquer quel programme qu'ils
soient satisfaits des français le
rapport à l'union européenne est une
question qui reste central la marine le
pen elle est protégée elle est dans
l'opposition ne la croyais pas pouvoir
accéder au pouvoir
elle a changé toutes ses positions sur
l'europe successivement ces dernières
années elle est à mille lieues de ce
qu'elle nous disait il ya quelques
années et personne ne lui en fait grief
est ce que demain maintenant elle est
prête à garder l'euro sortir de l'union
européenne il n'en est plus question
est-ce que du coup on va me regarder la
chaîne en se disant si elle est élue
quel programme applique-t-elle avec qui
gouverne hôtel est ce qu'on a vraiment
envie d'elle autant dire que c'est des
questions très forte
eh bien écoutez je vous propose de les
aborder lors d'une prochaine émission on
a quelques temps avant l'élection de
2022 devait qu'à ciel se tient à la date
prévue encore faudra-t-il connaître la
date de la présidentielle et avant des
régionales dont on n'a toujours pas la
date à madonna si vous permettez d'un
mot encore le fait que le président de
la république ait pris cette position de
non confinement rend plus difficile le
renvoi des élections régionales à plus
tard eh bien on continuera de le
commenter ça peut-être que vous viendrez
commenter avec nous des élections
régionales en plateau mon cher jérôme en
tout cas l'invitation est lancée
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis
merci france on lui dit le format
l'élection présidentielle est fait pour
la faire échouer au second tour et bien
ça c'est ce qu'on verra lors d'un
prochain débat également peut-être ou
l'avenir nous le dira la question qu'on
posait sur twitter marine le pen at-elle
de réelles chances pour 2022 pour
l'instant vous n'y croyez pas mais là
encore vous êtes peu vous êtes nombreux
à ne pas y croire qu' il y à quelques
temps quand on posait la question
notamment la semaine dernière merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivi et on se
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
normalement avec guillaume roquette a
très vite sur fear alive